SPEAKER 1: Good afternoon.
Today at Google we're delighted
to welcome Mr. Robin Sloan.
Mr. Sloan grew up in Detroit
and attended Michigan State,
where he co-founded a literary
journal called "Oats."
After college, he went to work
at the intersection of media
and technology, first in
St. Petersburg, Florida,
at the Poynter
Institute, and then
in San Francisco at
current TV and Twitter.
His first novel, "Mr.
Penumbra's 24-Hour Bookstore,"
went on to become a "New
York Times" best seller.
And it was called
by George Saunders
a "tour de force," after
which Mr. Sloan has politely
requested that no further
commentary on his writing
be offered.
Ever.
He's here today to discuss
his second novel titled
"Sourdough."
Please join me in welcoming
to Google, Mr. Robin Sloan.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBIN SLOAN: Thanks.
Hey, everybody.
Thanks for coming for
this, for getting out.
It's a nice intimate
crowd here in the flesh.
But I understand there are some
more people watching virtually,
and of course, more
people online later.
So here's what I would
like to propose--
I want to tell you a couple
of stories about this book.
One about where the idea
came from in the first place.
And one about where this
book kind of ended up for me.
Kind of like where I ended
up maybe after writing it.
And then, I want to
offer something else.
It's actually pretty Googley.
This is something that I
do all over-- at bookstores
and reading festivals.
But in a way, it's
even more apropos here.
And it's something that
I don't think you've ever
heard at a book reading before.
And then, of course,
I'll have time
to answer some questions if you
have them and we'll wrap it up.
Does that sound
like a good plan?
OK.
So this new book "Sourdough"
came about shortly
after I had wrapped
up the manuscript
for my first novel, which
was titled "Mr. Penumbra's
24-Hour Bookstore."
And I was in that state
of mind that follows--
I think only a first novel can
kind of put you in this space.
Because-- you guys might
have heard this before.
There's sort of a
saying or a cliche
about first novels, which is
that an author just opens up
their head and pours in
everything-- every thought
they've ever had, every dream
of a book they've ever dreamt.
Because you're not
sure you're ever
going to get to
write another one,
so like this is your chance.
And you put it all in.
That was definitely the case
with me and my first novel.
And so then my brain was empty.
I had kind of put
it all out there
and I had to figure out what I
was going to fill it up again
with to write this next book.
Of course, I am sure this is
true for a lot of the folks
in the audience here,
you're not struggling
to be interested in something.
You're actually interested
in too many things.
And so the challenge for me, at
that point, as I was beginning
to contemplate
this next book, was
what of all these different
paths am I going to choose?
And at that point, nothing
had really grabbed me
in that irresistible way.
So I'm thinking
about this stuff.
I'm sort of struggling
with the decision,
looking at all these interesting
things in the world and all
the different ways a novel could
go, when I went wine tasting.
I was up in Booneville.
Has anyone here ever
actually been to Booneville
up in Anderson Valley?
Yeah.
For those of you who haven't
been, well worth the trip.
It's about three hours north.
It's just this lovely
little green fold
of rustic wineries and
breweries and parks
and all sorts of
things like that.
I was up there tasting
wine at one winery
in particular--
tiny little place,
like a one-room
schoolhouse sort of.
They were very serious.
A little bit severe, actually,
in their whole approach
to wines.
Sort of unsmiling and like, you
should enjoy this and take it
very seriously.
And so they're pouring
one wine after another,
and they get to one somewhere
in the middle of this flight.
And the person who is helping
us set out those largest wine
glasses, the ones that are
like the big sort of globular
forms with their really
sharp, skinny edge.
And as she pouring this
wine-- which was a red wine--
inky dark.
Just dark, dark red.
She leaned forward a
little bit and her voice
was full of conspiracy--
I just remember this so well--
as she said to us,
very meaningfully,
"You know, this one
is a suitcase clone."
I see some looks sort of
confusion and consternation
in the audience.
I don't know if anyone here
had ever heard those two
words juxtaposed before.
I had not.
But I really liked the sound
of it-- "suitcase clone."
So I actually, at
that time, whipped
my notebook out
of my back pocket,
my ever present
notebook, into which
I put all interesting words
and phrases I ever run across.
Street signs or people's
names or little things
you overhear in cafes.
I whipped it out.
I said, hold on.
Say that again.
Suitcase clone?
OK.
What does that mean?
And so this is what she told me.
This is a real
thing, by the way.
This is totally just
documentary truth
from the history
of California wine.
Turns out, decades ago,
especially around the time when
California wine was starting to
take itself seriously as kind
of a peer to the wine makers
of the Old World-- you know,
France, Italy,
and all the rest--
in terms of quality, kind
of global reputation.
There was this thing
that people would do.
So let's say it's me.
Let's say I'm up there
in Anderson Valley.
I have some acreage on the
side of a hill somewhere.
And I imagine
myself a wine maker.
I want to plant
some grapes there.
What I might have done is found
a friend, an acquaintance,
perhaps someone in this room,
a faithful reader of one
of my books.
And said, how would you
like to take a trip?
All expenses paid
vacation to France,
one of the great old
winemaking regions.
Bordeaux.
Go.
For a week.
Enjoy yourself.
Eat good food.
Drink good wine.
Soak up the sun.
It'll be great.
So you do that.
You would have a good time.
But then, maybe, just maybe,
on the last day of your trip,
you could find yourself.
by chance, walking
down a path that
abuts one of those
great old vineyards.
Like, legendary.
Functioning for hundreds
of years in some cases.
And maybe haven taken that
path along that old vineyard,
you could suddenly notice
that your shoelace is untied.
And so then, of course,
you'll duck down low,
below the level of the vines.
And from some pocket produce
a little pair of garden snips.
Even just a pocket knife.
And you'll go snip, snip.
And take just a couple of
cuttings from these plants.
Then, you go back to the
B&B. You take a towel.
You wet it under the
tap, kind of wring it out
so it's not too soggy wet.
You wrap up those cuttings to
protect them for the journey
ahead, put them at the
bottom of your luggage.
Stack all your
other stuff on top.
And then book it
back to California.
Very importantly, you do not
declare those grape cuttings
at customs.
Instead, you bring them to
me up in Anderson Valley,
where I will take them.
I will graft them
onto American roots.
Help them grow.
And then I'll cut and
graft, cut and graft,
cloning that legendary
grape from whatever vineyard
in Bordeaux all
across my vineyard.
And so then I will have
exactly the same substance
from which to make my own wine.
As an aside, of course it's
not really the same substance.
And in fact, the entire
thing is a little bit silly,
because everything is different.
The soil is different.
The climate is different.
All the choices I make in my
cultivation are different.
But it has the
mystique, the aura.
And one thing is
indisputably true,
having done this whole
circuitous process,
I do get to tell people decades
later in my tasting room,
you know, this one
is a suitcase clone.
So I don't know how
that story strikes you
or what else it
makes you think of.
I can report to you that kind
to my surprise, I was entranced.
I was like, oh, I love it.
I just loved the
feeling of it, I think.
The combination of
something that's very--
or seems to be very--
traditional and
familiar and grounded,
like literally rooted.
Like, come on.
Like, grapes and winemaking.
With the very strange and
kind of the secret and just
the image of someone
like skulking
through a vineyard at night
or smuggling something
across borders.
That kind of spy vibe.
Those two things together
seemed to me really interesting
and really magnetic, honestly.
I mean, it was that
sense of irresistibly
that I'd been looking for.
So learning about the suitcase
clones up in Anderson Valley
sent me on this hunt for
other stories like that.
Other stories of normal or
traditional-seeming foods
and other things we eat with
kind of a secret back story.
I can report to you after doing
probably way too much research.
At a certain point, my
reading on all this stuff
turned into very
high-class procrastination.
But I learned a lot.
And I can report to you
now that the whole history
of food and
cultivation and eating
is more that than anything else.
Like everything that seems
normal and natural now,
everything that we
take for granted,
it was all smuggled and stolen
and misappropriated and moved
around the planet.
So this whole kind of world
of stuff I was learning
and all the stories
wrapped up in it
were so seductive, so perfect,
and they sent me on this path
to sort of writing this book.
I want to give you
a quick sense, just
a little tiny,
super short reading
from the book of
how that came out
the other end, like how some
of that emerged in the story.
So I'm going to read
you this tiny bit.
And what's happening here
is that the protagonist
of this novel has found her way
into a super secret underground
farmers market, where
all the people are
doing strange new
innovative things with food.
The most innovative
perhaps is a microbiologist
who is actually splicing
the genomes of microbes
in an effort to sort of
coax them into producing
some new potent kinds of food.
Some of her peers at this market
are understandably a little
skeptical of this whole program.
And they tell her, nope.
We are not OK with this.
We are not on board.
What you're doing
is not natural.
The microbiologist replies,
are you kidding me?
Nothing is natural.
And then following
that little argument,
there's another exchange
between two other characters.
And this is what they say--
"After the microbe
sequencing session was over,
I walked with Horace
through the grove
at the heart of the market.
'These are Meyer lemons,'
Horace said as we passed through
the lemon grove.
'They're named for
Frank Nicholas Meyer.
He was Dutch by birth but an
agent of the United States
government.
He worked for the Department
of Agriculture's Office
of Seed and Plant Introduction
before the First World War.
And I thought of him
when Dr. [? Jana ?] Mitra
spoke of her microbial survey.
Meyer and his cohort were
hunters for larger prey.
They crossed the
world and sent back
living samples of
plants thought to be
useful to the advancement
of the American economy.
Meyer worked in China.
He sent the first
soybean to America.
And persimmons.
Any persimmon grown
in this country today
comes from that lineage.
And of course, there are
these lemons named for him.
Meyer died in China.
He drowned in the Yangtze,
pushed from a river boat.'
I looked at the lemon trees
with new found appreciation.
Horace continued, 'He sent
these across the Pacific
and the Spanish sent tomatoes
to Italy in the 16th Century.
And the Portuguese--
chiles to India.
Maybe a comet brought it all
the earth in the first place.
Who knows?
Oh, I quite agree with
Dr. [? Jana ?] Mitra.'
He plucked a lemon from a tree.
'Nothing is natural.'"
So that's a big part of
the philosophy of this book
and a lot of the sort of
characters and the work they do
and the arguments they
have, kind of bound up
in that question of
what is traditional?
What is normal?
What is natural?
Maybe nothing really is.
But of course, I've been telling
you about wine and grapes
and suitcase clones.
And the title of this book
is not the suitcase clone,
it's "Sourdough."
So what happened?
As I was writing this book,
I discovered two things--
one kind of personal, the other
one actually quite mechanical.
The personal thing is
that I don't actually
care about wine that much
or at least not enough
to write a whole novel set
in kind of the world of wine
and wine making.
The mechanical thing, though--
this is pretty nerdy.
It kind of gets into the weeds
of how fiction comes together.
But I think there's
people who tend
to be interested in
this kind of stuff.
I discovered something
that surprised me.
I was trying to sort of sequence
these stories about wine
and figure out how
things might happen
and how you might discover
the secret of, say,
this super mysterious
suitcase clone.
And I realized that
almost by definition
a story about winemaking
runs really slow.
Its clock ticks year by year
by year, vintage by vintage
by vintage.
So again, almost by definition
the book you're going to write
is going to be this sort
of slow generational story.
And members of a
family are going
to be getting older,
relationships shifting.
They're going to be
harvesting grapes every year.
And sure enough, you'll learn
things about this grape year
by year.
And eventually, someone
will kind of crack the code
and its mysterious origins
will become apparent.
But it's going to happen after
years and years and years.
The dog-- the golden
retriever in the field,
it's muzzle getting gray.
And it's all sort of very warm
and nostalgic and all that.
Sounds like an interesting book.
I would probably read
that book, actually.
But I didn't think
it was the kind
of book that I wanted to
write or the kind that I'd
be good at writing.
The kind of books that I write
best, I think, at least so far,
are books that are about now.
Books about the moment we're in
and maybe kind of the next 15
minutes into the future.
That's just what I'm
interested in myself.
That's what gets me excited.
So figuring out how I was
going to anchor this story that
was going to be about food
and eating and the mysteries
and the secrets kind of
bound up in these worlds,
it came almost like
balancing an equation
from like middle school math.
Like really, really simple.
You've got some
things that you want
to hold constant and
another value that you're
trying to find.
So the things I was holding
constant were the following--
food and eating and
secret histories.
I mean, that was what I had
gotten so fascinated by.
I wanted the sort of
the core substance
or the sort of sub-genre
of food and eating
to be something I
actually cared more about
and was more intrinsically
interested in myself
and maybe something I
knew more about naturally.
And finally, importantly,
it had to be something
with a faster clock speed.
Something that could
reveal its secrets.
Something you could kind of work
with and ask questions about,
not year by year by year,
but day by day by day,
or even faster.
You know, hour by hour by hour.
And truly, I
discovered the solution
that kind of balanced
this equation
perfectly sitting there
in a scummy little Mason
jar in my kitchen.
And it was my sourdough starter.
And for anyone who doesn't
know, which some people take it
so for granted, but other people
actually never learned this.
And I was one of them
until not that long ago.
Sourdough starter is a little
community of microorganisms.
You feed it every day, if
you're a sourdough baker.
And it kind of rises and falls.
And it's a key ingredient
in being sourdough bread.
It gives it its texture by kind
of inflating and producing gas.
It also gives it a lot of
its flavor just because
of some of the chemicals that
these little microbes produce.
And truly, it is less
ingredient and more roommate.
It is like a little
gang of living organisms
that you have to care
for and kind of respect
their demands in some cases.
So I realized that sourdough
was going to be it for me.
Sourdough was going
to be the key.
Because you can
use it every day.
And just like a cutting
from a grape plant,
a sourdough starter, in
it's little container,
could of course be
something that someone
smuggled across borders,
under cover of darkness.
So that's the core of the story.
It is, indeed, about a
mysterious sourdough starter
that it soon becomes apparent
has properties, powers perhaps,
that are much stranger than
your everyday San Francisco
sourdough starter.
I actually think that in the
history of English literature
so far, as far as I
know-- as far as I've
been able to kind of research--
this is the first novel
to feature as a very
important supporting character
a sentient sourdough starter.
And I'm proud of
that distinction.
So I want to share with you guys
something that kind of sprung
immediately out of
that decision to anchor
this book in the
sourdough starter,
and something that's actually
very quite Googley, I think.
So as you may or
might not know--
might or might not know, audio
books are super popular, just
like soaring popularity.
They are the part of
the publishing industry
that's growing.
Everything else is kind of
maintaining and kind of trying
to keep it together and stay
healthy and just kind of fight
the tides of digital stuff.
Audio books are this one great
exception where they're just
going like gangbusters.
So appropriately,
audio book producers
are taking their task
really seriously.
They're trying to produce
things that are not just
kind of flat recitations
of the words on the page,
but are productions
in their own right.
So one of things they do
is they reach out to you--
the author of a book about to be
transformed into an audio book.
They ask you for something
different, something special.
They want to make the
audio book distinct.
So sure enough, for the
"Sourdough" audio book,
I wrote a little
bit of extra text.
Just a few little nuggets that
we kind of slipped in there,
almost as like Easter eggs, for
people who listened to the book
rather than read it on the page.
But there's something else, too.
That something else has
to do with the story.
It has to do with the
sourdough starter.
In my sort of
fictional imaginings
it is brought to San
Francisco by a couple
of mysterious brothers.
They are from a culture--
pun not totally intended--
that is very mysterious,
not known by many people.
And it has a few
sort of things--
hallmarks-- of its
people and its history.
One of them is this particular
sourdough starter, which
had been going for a long time.
They bake their bread with it.
And it is very, very good bread.
But then to go along with
that, they have songs.
They have a particular
genre of music.
And they actually sing these
songs to the sourdough starter.
And it's really important
to its development.
And I mean, truly, these
two things together--
the starter and the songs--
they make the whole story go.
Without them, nothing happens.
This is just the story of a sort
of mildly depressed software
engineer in San Francisco.
So I talk about it so much and
I write so many descriptions
of this music.
This, of course, is the
great affordance of fiction.
I can write something like--
just for example--
Lois pressed play
on the blank CD
that one of the mysterious
brothers had given her.
The music started to play slow
and sad, nothing but voices,
curling together, in a language
that she didn't recognize,
but danced just on the
edge of legibility--
And you're like, oh, OK.
I can kind of hear it, right?
I mean this is
how fiction works.
You write something that kind of
gets the reader halfway there,
and then you let them go
the rest of way themselves.
Every novel exists
probably more than halfway
towards the reader's mind than
the authors, which is amazing.
I think this is why this is such
an amazing and powerful medium.
But knowing that I
was describing music--
audio-- this is an audio
book, I had the sense
it was going to be frustrating
if somebody listened
to the entire however many
dozens of hours of this thing
and didn't get to hear
at least the tiniest
whisper of this fictional music.
It was like, come on.
Seriously?
So this was a challenge,
because we could not
afford to hire the people
who invent Dothraki for "Game
of Thrones," much less a choir
to perform it and then record
it and play on the audio book.
So we needed something a
little more rough and ready.
Because I live and work here
in the San Francisco Bay area
and am interested in code and
technology and all these things
and have been
forever, and just am
an inveterate kind of tinkerer
and explorer with these things,
I knew about machine learning.
I knew what some of the
tools were capable of.
And I tinkered with
them a bit myself.
And of course, as some of
you might already know,
one of the things that a
machine learning system can do
is sort of extract patterns.
You can give it this big
set of training data.
It can be text; images;
indeed, even audio.
And set this challenge.
Say, I want you to
kind of figure out
what the pieces of this are.
What makes this the way it is?
And then I want you to be able
to generate new things that
fit those patterns.
You're not allowed to
just copy and paste.
You can't just playback
what I gave you.
You've got to come up
with something new,
but it has to kind of fit that
pattern in a really rough way.
I'd run experiments with
text and the results
were weird but
compelling, I thought.
Actually, really
creatively provocative.
And so I had the sense that
maybe I could apply this
to the problem of the music.
So just to kind of
get you up to speed
where I was starting from,
there was a kind of music--
or there is a kind
of music-- that's
real that I had listened to
for years and really enjoyed.
It was kind of in my
head when I was imagining
this mysterious language and
this mysterious slow, sad music
in the book.
That kind of real music is
called Klapa, K-L-A-P-A.
It's Croatian.
It's all acappella,
sort of choral singing.
It's really lovely.
I'm going to play you
a little example here.
And I think I can just
play it into my microphone
and it'll work OK.
This is real life
Croatian Klapa music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's nice.
It also kind of
sounds like that.
A big part of the appeal
for me, of course,
is that do not
understand Croatian,
so it has that
sort of opaqueness,
like, oh, what are
they singing about?
Oh, I don't know, but it's
so sort of melancholic
and slow and sad.
I just love it.
I knew we couldn't just put
Klapa in the audio book,
because even if it kind
of does the trick for me,
there's plenty of people in the
world who do speak Croatian.
They'd be like, why is
their weird Croatian
song in this audio book?
The songs are all
about something.
I mean, it just seemed
kind of in poor taste,
in fact, to sort of take
somebody else's language
and say, no, no, no.
I'm going to use it as
my fictional stand in.
Wanted to use this machine
learning method instead
to create something that
was no language at all.
No language on earth.
So I took my collection of
Croatian Klapa mp3s, lovingly
assembled over the years.
Just this big kind of
junk pile of things
I'd scraped from all
sorts of sources online.
I fed those into
a neural network.
And I set up this task.
I was like learn the
patterns, like learn something
of the essence that makes
this music what it is.
And then use that to
generate some new music.
So this is what I got.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So it's pretty weird.
To my ear, at least, it is
weird in like the right way.
It has that sense.
And there's reasons for this.
You can hear the
human voices there.
You can tell that that's
something human, the sort
of syllables and phonemes
and little fragments,
but it's not Croatian.
It's definitely not English.
It's, in fact, no
language at all.
I think that's actually
sort of exciting,
an exciting creative artifact.
We could take the snippets
of this music-- oh,
so I should complete
the thought.
I generated a bunch of sounds
just like the ones you heard,
like hundreds, most
of which were just
too weird to kind
of even contemplate.
But some of which, just
out of pure chance, kind of
had a loveliness to them.
Some interesting
things were happening.
So I curated those down.
I zipped them up.
And I attached them to an email,
which I sent to the audio book
producers.
And I really, really hope that
that's like the weirdest thing
they've ever gotten.
And the task, I said, listen.
This is actually kind of what I
imagine this music sounds like.
So if you can find
some snippets in here
that you can use, feel free to
cut and paste, and manipulate,
do whatever you need to do.
But maybe we can find a way to
slip this into the audio book.
Sure enough, the audio
book for "Sourdough"
is, as far as I know,
the first audio book ever
to feature in its experience
the output of a neural network.
Small distinctions.
I will take them.
I will always take
a small distinction
that no one else cares about.
There's one other thing I want
to share before I close out
and answer some
of your questions.
One of things I
learned producing all
of these weird little tracks--
of course, they were
always unpredictable.
They just always had
sort of a different shape
and a different sound.
Of course, the way this works--
some of you will
know this already,
but for those of you who don't--
it was all probabilistic.
I always take great pains
describing this project
not to use the word
artificial intelligence,
because there are some things
that sort of are beginning
to dance toward that boundary.
Something that you really
could call like "AI."
This, assuredly, is not.
It's totally statistical
and kind of probabilistic.
It's really just about
learning a statistical model
of a particular thing.
The way that works--
it works the same way
with text, with images,
with sound, when you're
using these techniques.
If we're talking about text--
and I had asked this thing
not to learn Croatian Klapa,
but to learn Melville
or to learn Harry Potter
or like any kind of
English prose, one
of the things it
would have learned
at the most basic level is that
given the letter T and then
the letter H, the next
letter it ought to generate
is almost certainly E or A or O.
I mean, definitely a
vowel, something like that.
It is definitely not-- or
with such a vanishingly low
probability--
Z or Q or X. And you
can imagine very easily
kind of building a network
of all these probabilities
as they all build one on
another on another on another.
And eventually, you end up with
this really sort of interesting
and powerful statistical model
of how you make a sentence
from a Harry Potter book.
It's really cool, but it's
also strangely simple.
So one of things I
learned, to my surprise,
is that following
that same model,
one of these neural
networks trained
on Croatian choral music--
or I suspect any kind
of recorded music--
one of the first
things it learns
is that if it selects
a sample of silence
or just like a really,
really quiet sample and then
another sample of
silence, there's
a very, very good chance,
it ought to next select
another sample of silence.
Because it turns out
little chunks of silence
are one of the
most common things.
It's one of the most
reliable sort of artifacts
in any one of these files.
There are the big silence
at the beginning, the fade
out at the end.
Even the spaces
between movements,
or even in the case of this
choral music, the spaces
where the whole choir takes
a breath, and they all go--
[GASP]
And it kind of just vanishes
into this void for a minute.
And of course, these
neural networks,
they don't have a sense
of the whole track.
They only have a sense of this
small window they're looking
at at any particular time.
And so they become very,
very confident in silence.
They're like, OK.
One really quiet sample.
Another quiet sample.
Oh, I got this.
And then having generated
that quiet sample,
I'm even more sure that the
next one ought to be silent,
and on and on and on.
What that meant is
that very often, I
would ask this neural network
to generate a new 30-second song
or a minute-long song.
It would kind of
churn and crunch.
It would take a little while to
do that-- five minutes or seven
minutes.
And it would spit out this file.
And I would very
excitedly hit play
to see what the new
song was going to be.
And I would hear--
this totally confident nothing.
So I got very used to kind
of just dragging those
into the trash and trying again.
There was, however, in addition
to the sort of very confident
silent tracks and then the
sort of more interesting sort
of bubbling percolating tracks,
like the one I played first,
there was a third kind, too.
And it actually
became my favorite.
I just want to share
it with you now,
because I think it's sort of a
remarkable creative artifact.
Of course, these probabilities
are not definite.
I mean, they're all just
sort of like values--
smushy values on a wide scale.
And so even if something has
a super small chance of ever
happening-- you know 1/10,000
of 1% or whatever it is--
you run the computer for long
enough and it can happen.
So sure enough, some
of these files open up
and the computers just locked
into this confident groove
of silence, like, ha ha,
what could be easier?
Yes.
I have learned the secrets
of human composition--
silence!
And it goes on and
on and on and on.
But in each one
of those samples,
some calculation is being made.
And who knows what happens?
At one moment, something
trembles in the computer's
little random number
generator and it
sparks just enough
to tip a domino
in a different
direction, and having
tipped in that other direction,
we're off to the races.
Because suddenly,
you're not calculating
what's sort of most
confidently following
silence but something else.
And I love that moment.
I think it's really
beautiful, actually,
because there's
no reason for it.
It just happens sometimes.
I want to share one with you.
This is a track that
I started playing,
and at first, I
despaired, because I
thought it was going
to be another one
of these silent ones.
But I was a little bit patient.
And so I want you to be a
little bit patient, too.
It's going to start with
silence, which is by design,
but then you're going to hear
just a little ways in something
in the universe trembles, and
we get something else instead--
[BEEP]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No reason for any
of that to happen.
But it did happen.
And it's really lovely.
And I have decided that I think
that is what "having an idea"
sounds like.
With that, I'll say
thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: "Penumbra" had a lot
of interesting literary devices
in it, like from the short
story where the narrator is
really unreliable and you never
see any exact quotes they have.
So I'm kind of curious,
what literary devices
should I be looking
forward to in this book?
ROBIN SLOAN: Oh, that
is a good question.
I don't know that I have
a direct answer, often
because those tricky little
things emerge, sometimes
even to my own surprise
in this writing.
I kind of follow a feeling
and realize only in retrospect
that I've hopefully done
something interesting.
I did try to make the starter,
the sourdough starter,
a character.
I wanted it to be not just an
object but sort of a character
with a will of its
own in the story.
But I wanted to do so in
like a hard sci-fi way.
It never talks.
It never goes, "I am
the sourdough starter.
Thank you for unlocking me."
It operates in a way
that I think is credible.
At a certain point,
it gets pretty weird.
But I think it's all
within the realm of what's
possible in our real universe.
And so I guess
that's the thing I
would say to look for--
the way that I have
it sort of communicate
and talk and express
its opinions to the narrator.
I don't know.
I don't know if I succeeded
in what I set out to do,
but I wanted to make this
thing seem like a character
without making it
like a cartoon.
AUDIENCE: It seems like your
books span multiple genres.
How would you classify them?
ROBIN SLOAN: That's
a hard question.
I don't really believe
in genres anymore.
And I think there's
good reason not to.
They're getting so blurred
and people are reading
so deeply into one genre only
to extract ideas and then
use them in a different genre.
The books sit on the
fiction shelf, which I guess
is the best shelf for them now.
Earlier, I was chatting
with some other people
about the idea of a new genre
called puzzle fiction, which
I'm sort of newly excited about.
But if there was a
shelf at a bookstore--
it was like there's
the fiction shelf
here and the
science-fiction shelf here.
And then there was just a little
shelf that was between them,
and it was for like
books both written by
and I guess written
for people who
love the contents of both
those shelves, that's
the right home for I think
everything that I write.
Well, cool.
Thank you, guys, for your time.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for coming out.
And also, I'll be happy to
sign your books if you want.
[APPLAUSE]